Sean would we be able to hold up the two
cards okay so we have the character and
plot cards so an aging Butler
reminiscing about their Glory Days and
discovers a terrible secret about their
own family so our working title is the
internal Butler yes and we're still
fleshing out ideas do you have any
potential subplots you can imagine well
I think we've kind of now that we've
decided that you know this Butler will
be in the First Act in this kind of
comfortable and maybe working
environment where they're in their home
where they've been their entire career
and perhaps their father was a butler
before that and the father was a butler
before that uh and then a terrible
family secreted discovered perhaps that
they're even you know related to the
other family or that there has been you
know whatever it is that you know
questions his his entire life and what
he believes in because he was truly
someone who believed in whatever that
cause was in that household or whatever
that was uh and then it turns out that a
lot of that is not true and he literally
strips his Garb of Butler ship of
butlering and wonders out and perhaps
even first you know leave some life of
debauchery
uh you know perhaps just gets a little
weight down drunk and maybe gets into a
fight and ends up on a bus and it's out
in the middle of nowhere and ends up at
this
somewhat
dilapidated Desert Hotel
that is run by a you know I still
haven't decided exactly who's running it
and I think that the drag Wing would be
too obvious at this point in our way do
we watch movies but perhaps maybe a
someone that you know like a a gruffal
dude like another gruffle dude that they
can kind of just butt up against like
maybe a gruffal black dude if it's a
Gruff white day yeah whatever it is just
somebody who's really just where they
can really just have the gruffle dude
thing uh you know and because the Aging
Butler is going to be he's gonna still
he's going to be very set in what he
what he perceives as what things should
be
uh and there will be a lot of people
trying to tell him that that's not the
way things are
and I think that's what's going to be
really interesting I think I'm bringing
a lot of the comedic elements that I
could see in it as well
um
yeah
so and then yes well I guess go what you
were going to say yeah I was thinking
because you know sometimes like people
that work sort of on the outskirts of a
lot of wealth money and things they
adopt those same principles even though
they don't really have it but they kind
of almost have this delusion that they
do and they become snobs I've seen that
a lot so I maybe he has a snobbery about
him but then they kind of strip them
away of that like if you're so great why
are you here what what land did you hear
you know absolutely it's it's the it's
it's exactly that it's exactly who are
you and you know you just wander it out
here you don't have any money anything
you're maybe now he's been put to work
there you know and he's trying to like
help at this hotel you know this kind of
hotel and I've always loved been
fascinated by like kind of low end
hotels or motels maybe it's a hotel and
not just a motel but a hotel like a kind
of like a just a you know it used to be
this great you know Palm Springs or
Palmdale duster was trying to be this
great it just never was so it's like the
Royale or something like that and it
just never was quite that Royal you know
just never was quite that it's just a
little bit too dingy you know but you
know that I think that would be
fascinating or or it used to be and then
the sun inherited sort of the nerdwell
sun inherited it and then his own
whatever issues took it down and the
area changed yeah I think so and I I
definitely see this now as a 70s era
film like I for some reason I'm just
fascinated by how this would look as in
the 70s
um and just like the whole you know
especially like late 60s early 70s like
where it's still kind of like because
then they're like the hotels like there
there's hippies and you know and you
know free livers and granola eaters and
you know and and then there's also just
maybe like the people were just kind of
like
I'm just trying to survive you know just
trying to like those first families
coming over the Border just trying to
find a place to you know figure things
out or just survive essentially
some Vietnam Vets Vietnam Vets you know
I I also also see for some reason it's
making me see a lilies in the field
don't ask me why but like I do I just
see Sidney Poitier kind of you know
helping out the whatever and I kind of
see some of that like well we've got to
build uh something or we've got to do
something we've got to you know do
something that that makes whatever that
brings them all together
type of thing in a very simplistic
manner
is there an inciting incident that takes
the Butler from the contained beautiful
clean world of the family home where he
has maybe an outburst and realizes you
know I think it's the disguise I think
it's just the the overwhelming reality
of his reality being crushed by
discovering a secret that's you know
within that environment I think his I
think his
he's put so much on it by now at this
point in his life that that will just
take him out
well he maybe throw some dishes or no I
just think that just like he'll just end
up questioning everything
who he is what he is where he's been
what he's been doing for his entire life
thinking that he was putting something
into this and it turns out that they're
worth not worth it
whatever it is
does he give us two weeks notice does he
do the gentleman's no I think it's like
he barely I think he can barely even you
know I think it's like a
a not I think it's like one of those
things where whoever he discovers or
whoever whatever they make an excuse for
him and even hope that he may come back
and lie whatever the deal thinking that
he may but and maybe even trying to so
worried about them him knowing that and
have something that they've got to be
hunting him down
to try to find him so we got we got a
little witness scenario going on which
could be hunting him down in the Wake
would be like just something around to
like eliminate the secret
yeah if we want to make it if we want to
raise the stakes just raise the stakes
and also too maybe he knows these other
secrets that don't involve him but the
family secrets he knows he knows so much
that they're now concerned it but he
feels that he's so portrayed that
they're worried that he would actually
portray when they've never been worried
about it but now it's like because they
are that nefarious that they may that it
may be just sending him out to eliminate
him
so now I've raised now we've raised the
stakes and we've also created a ticking
clock which is very fun he had a little
sister act action going on
and also too there might be a um you
don't appreciate us we we helped you you
know seeing sort of um
you know you're good as long as you're
underneath us but if you try to become
our equal that we can't have that and
don't you know we helped you kind of
thing yes and then now you've also made
a movie that has potential to be a
bigger movie with us still that still
the same budget level
with just like some ticking to clock
elements adding a little bit you know
maybe not going too far over the top in
the hotel but just making it kind of
heartwarming and you know the characters
like not so over the top but you know
cocoon 2 but you know maybe more than
cocoon 2 because that would be a little
too mundane but now not making it like
that uh
Robert De Niro movie that Michael
Schumacher directed that was he
was uh oh and it did Philip Seymour
Hoffman in it what was that movie
uh essentially where he was a cop
Janeiro was a cop that gets hurt and the
only person that can take care of him is
Phillip Seymour Hoffman's drag queen
character in the hotel
so that type of that type of thing
because you can bring those types of
casting to something like that if you
can bring characters that care that
they're interested in playing
what are your final notes on this story
before we move on
I'm starting to like it more I think
it's starting to have some potential
bringing in some of the elements that
I'm discussing like from like lilies in
the field to you know the ticking clock
element with like kind of like uh which
makes me think of witness
um with you know being out with the
different lifestyle in a different place
um but then having that Invader come
into that kind of sacred place now
that's been sacred and have to fight
back type of thing so you can have two
you essentially have
the character going through almost three
little mini movies on some level uh
which people will I think the genre band
would be interesting so I'm excited
about I love genre bends by the way so
what other characters would you like to
see in this story
um you know I definitely see in the
family that whatever that family is that
will be there you know almost a
semblance of normalcy and balance
um
I definitely for some reason see this
Gruff kind of counter character that's
going to be maybe it was even a woman
that you know he just doesn't get along
with doesn't get along with and that's
the person that he'll end up getting
along with
uh so I see that kind of like that kind
of like friction type of thing for
somebody who was never looking for a
deal funny that part of that
breakthrough will I think be having some
kind of a real love relationship
um for someone who's given that away you
know giving up that possibility I think
that's people who get that Gruff are
often people who have let those things
like that possibility go and I think by
reopening that channel up from him will
creep that and so that character that
can do that and that will be there so I
see that uh and um
definitely you know like somebody who's
a performer or someone who's like kind
of says one thing but really doesn't
know that he can really just Mentor in
some way and maybe that's in the family
uh maybe that's all of them in some
level giving them certain things that he
can supply
um that where he can see some value
again in his life so it's really those
people that can reflect those things
back to him they're going to give the
best version of or the worst version of
the internal
Butler
when he gets to the hotel is he viewed
as a threat no he's viewed more as kind
of like a somebody may be a little local
a little crazy but you know definitely
not a threat you know someone more who's
like a
grew someone to be humored or even feel
sorry for because maybe there's just
like some homeless dude who's gotten
this idea you know they don't know you
know they do who he is or what what he's
lived he's like even though it's like
you know it's still what he's
experiences still in many ways more than
they can ex they've experienced and at
that level and it takes a certain thing
so they're not even giving credit for
that in the beginning
so I think it'll be he'll just be like
yo you're just a homeless dude just
watered in here with all these weird
stories you know be quiet yeah be lucky
you're here and clean the pool or
whatever it is
maybe I'm envisioning like a laundry
room scene where let's suppose
somebody's left their laundry in the
dryer and hasn't removed it for hours
and he becomes enraged because maybe he
would never do that because then the
clothes would wrinkle so he his his
training starts to come out and his sort
of very rigid uh way of of keeping a
home in order and they're kind of
shocked by it and they realize oh maybe
he's telling the truth
I I definitely see that there'll be
opportunities for him to have to kind of
like
we to earn to re-earn his own trust and
to earn their trust in the sense of who
he is as a person
and in that process of that the or in
even having to in some level
subjugate himself or be not the butler
because the butler is essentially the
head of the household the butler's not
just a servant the butler is a head of
a household of servants so they're
responsible for not just whatever their
duties are but making sure everyone
within that household and usually we
actually have a butler you have you know
traditionally if you a true one you you
have a staff of you know five or two
five to ten servants
um or if you're you're one gentleman
gentlemen where you have you know a
butler who essentially is a travel
companion where they're with that person
almost 24 hours again in serving that
person so they essentially live their
lifestyle
um so that you know understanding those
types of things I think would be like
understanding that background and what
they've seen and what they've learned uh